RAMACHANDRAN IYER: Welcome.
Hi, I'm Ram.
I'm part of the marketplace
platforms at Uber.
NANDAKUMAR GOPALAKRISHNAN:
Hi, I'm Nanda.
I do work in marketplace
platforms at Uber.
RAMACHANDRAN IYER:
Here's our agenda today.
We'll start with an
overview of Uber scale
and some of the key challenges
we were looking to solve.
We'll then look at what
it took us to evaluate
Cloud Spanner and
the systems we had
to build to enable our
platform on Spanner.
We will then deep dive into
some technical learnings
and what we plan to do next.
Let's look at what
scale means at Uber.
Uber started back in
2010, and our systems
have constantly needed to
scale as business has evolved.
As an engineer, one of
the fun things at Uber
is the opportunity to
build systems at scale.
Here are some of
the numbers, based
on Q1, which essentially
highlights what's
the scale of our operations.
We did close to
18 million rides,
which includes trips
and deliveries,
each day on the Uber platform.
We had close to 5 million active
drivers and delivery people
and have close to 103 million
monthly active platform
consumers.
Uber is a global company with
a presence in 10,000 cities
and 69 countries
across six continents.
From the Eats side, we have
400,000 restaurant partners
operating globally
in 45 countries.
A scale like this
creates a unique set
of technical challenges.
The marketplace platform
team is responsible
for the fulfillment
platform which
facilitates the
core transportation
flows for Rides and Eats.
We are huge into microservices.
We have a robust
infrastructure running
on thousands of nodes across
hundreds of microservices,
and the complexity in running
so many services increases
as we scale.
Let's look at a simple example
of an offer acceptance flow.
To your left, we
can see a snapshot
of the offer screen presented
to a driver for a Rides trip.
The driver has an option
to accept or decline.
And from the driver's
point of view,
it's just tap of a button,
but a lot of things
happen in the back.
These drivers and
riders are modeled
as entities in our system.
And when state changes
occur, all these entities
need to be updated
transactionally.
As an example, once the
driver accepts the offer,
the rider also needs to be
associated with that driver,
and all the downstream
systems need
to be updated and kept in sync.
Also, the presented offer needs
to auto-expire if no action has
been taken after a few seconds.
And the feedback
for this also needs
to be propagated in
downstream systems.
These entities are more
or less state machines
as it undergoes various entity
state transitions from start
to finish of a trip.
Now, this is a
very simple example
of a two-sided marketplace
involving a driver and a rider.
The complexity
increases with Eats,
which is a three-sided
marketplace involving
a restaurant, a delivery
person, and an eater,
also, with some
advanced use cases,
like trying to batch more trips
together for products like Uber
Pool and Eats deliveries.
The fulfillment platform handles
all these real-time use cases.
So more than a year back,
we took a holistic look
at our architecture with an aim
to simplify and modernize them.
Let's look at how we approached.
We categorized our challenges
into the following dimensions.
One was focused on
platform efficiency
and the other on
data management.
On platform efficiency, a lot
of product teams across Uber
used the fulfillment platform
to build business features.
We have to ensure that we
build extensible components
across all our product lines
without introducing complexity.
At the same time,
we want to make
sure we maximize on our
infrastructure efficiency
by improving
throughput per Core.
Given the scale of Uber, even
an incremental improvement
here can have a
meaningful impact
on the overall
infrastructure spent.
From data management
point of view,
our current application
architecture
relies on an eventually
consistent model
and adds complexity in
the application layer
to deal with consistency.
Also, when you have
so microservices,
state management across all
of them is a huge challenge.
For our systems to be reliable,
we need a strongly consistent
and an available database
that can scale to our needs
and can also support complex
transactions at scale.
To overcome these
constraints, we
use solutions at
application level,
like maintaining transaction
queues, sticky sharding,
along with leveraging ring
flop for coordination,
and some patterns around
transaction orchestration.
But if you think about it, this
application-level complexity
can be simplified by
pushing some of them
to the database load.
So we classified our
database requirements further
into system and
usability aspects.
From systems requirement, we
wanted an ACID-compliant system
which can give us fine
lines of availability
and comes with globally
consistent guarantees.
Uber has multiple data
centers, so the solution
should work across
data centers and should
satisfy our latency issues.
From a usability standpoint,
we wanted support
for relational modeling.
Based on the
previous example, we
wanted support for a
multifaceted marketplace
where business entities
are highly relational.
It should have
good absorbability
for tracking and tracing
issues, and should
be easy to scale as
the business grows.
So with these
requirements, which
are super high level
in mind, the team
looked at different
database solutions.
We chose Cloud
Spanner for evaluation
as it satisfied all of
our core requirements.
As we started ideating our
solution on top of Spanner,
we went through a
process of identifying
the gaps of what we
needed to build before we
could start using Spanner.
Here are some of
the things which we
built specific to our use case.
Our programming model
is highly asynchronous,
and we wanted all our Spanner
RPCs to be asynchronous, too.
For this, we built an
async Spanner client
so that it can fit into
our execution model--
a Background Task
Execution system.
We built an event-sourcing
solution on top of Spanner
which we will look into
greater detail further down.
TTL-- as part of a
real-time platform,
we needed support for TTL.
So once a trip ends or
an order has fulfilled,
the data gets handled by a
post-trip processing platform.
TTL support is needed so
the data can be cleaned up
once it's no longer needed
by the real-time platform.
A transaction
execution framework.
We optimized on
different strategies
for executing our
transactions and also built
tooling around detecting
log contentions and ENDLOG.
Lastly, for monitoring,
since all our metrics
are persisted in our internal
systems, some of which
are also open source,
like Entry and Jaeger,
we wanted Spanner's
server-side metrics
also to be available internally
and closely-integrated
with our monitoring
and alerting systems.
Let's look at some
of them more closely.
We started off with a very
lightweight Spanner client
generated using Google's
open source API generator
and built on top of the RPC.
This is a Java client.
And as mentioned
previously, this
aligns closely and well with
our async programming pattern.
It also gives us a
better handle for tuning
client-side resources.
We added more
functionality to the client
as part of session and
transaction management.
To give some more
context, a session
acts as a communication
channel, and you can only
run one transaction at
a time on a session.
They are reusable resources,
so we build session pooling
from ground up which can
auto scale based on usage.
For transactions, we built
different transaction execution
strategies to reduce
our transaction time.
More on this later
with an example.
On observability front, we
wanted to integrate it closely
with our internal
observability platforms,
like logging,
metrics, and tracing.
To talk more on other systems
and solutions we built,
I will hand over to Nanda,
who will take it from here.
NANDAKUMAR GOPALAKRISHNAN:
Thanks, Ram.
To give you some context,
we wanted a system
for executing
background async tasks
with at least one guarantee.
We were looking for an
event-sourcing solution
on top of Spanner.
Such a solution would be used
for things like publishing
internal state change
events or to kick off
post-trip processing, like
sending customer notifications
for things like
ratings, et cetera.
These tasks would be registered
as part of the same transaction
as for other entities.
For example, the driver
has ended the trip.
The task to do
post-trip processing
would also be
registered as part of
the same end-trip transaction.
Moreover, these
tasks also needed
to have a timer property
where they can be scheduled
to execute at
sometime in future,
or they can be scheduled to
execute tasks periodically.
To build such a system,
we introduced a task table
where we can store all
the registered tasks.
We then built an efficient
scanner, also known as Tailers,
that scans through this
table and schedules them
in memory for execution.
They were named as
Tailers inspired
by the Unix terminology, as the
scans only look for new data.
We were able to horizontally
scale the system
by having multiple tailers
at those different shards
so that each scan got
its own key space.
This approach
allowed us to detect
any new tasks for
background execution
within milliseconds of
them being registered.
Another system that we built was
a Spanner Monitoring service,
which is a standalone
monitoring service that
inputs critical
Stackdriver metrics
into our internal
monitoring stack.
The reason why we did--
why we built this, was to
have Spanner Monitoring
well-integrated with our
internal systems, especially
dating and metric analysis.
Some of the analysis that we
were able to perform well,
session analysis, that is to
check if sessions are properly
reused and for how long.
Then transaction
analysis, to analyze
long-running transactions.
That is Spanner provides
interesting stats which
allows us to introspect and dive
deeper into queries and BMLs
taking longer time.
To get this data from
Spanner and index
it internally, making it
easier to search and analyze.
Building a Spanner monitoring
service allowed us to build--
also allowed us to build
an autoscaler functionality
recently.
To scale Spanner
nodes in an elastic,
were based on various
server side parameters
like Spanner CPU
Utilization and Storage.
While building these systems
and testing Spanner at scale,
we came across some
learnings that we
would like to share that
helped us along the way.
Let's dive deeper technically.
The first thing is
request patterns.
So it's important to have
good understanding of request
patterns in order to come
up with the right schema.
It is also equally
important to understand
how Spanner performs reads
and writes for such a pattern.
For us, we had three
types of patterns,
simple CRUD-like operations
on a given group.
For such cases, completely
random primary key,
like UUID works really great.
It gives us the best
possible distribution
and also avoids hot spots.
For multi-year updates or
for accessing related items,
use interleaved-tables.
It gives locality without
[? intros, ?] ensuring
your joints are efficient.
The other use case,
as mentioned before,
was to build an
efficient scanner that
scans through new rows.
Frequent row deletions
in your table
can cause tombstones, which can
make your scans inefficient,
causing higher scan latencies.
For such use cases,
a combination
of shardId and Spanner
Timestamp works really well.
The problem with
timestamps in a key,
either primary or secondary,
is that it can cause hot spots.
Using shardId prevents the hot
spots and at the same time,
allows multiple workers
to scan individual shards
and [INAUDIBLE].
There were quite a
few learnings for us
with respect to how we do
transactions on Spanner.
So the first one was to
optimize for reducing
read/write transaction time.
Read/write transaction
time is measured
as the time between the first
operation in a transaction
to the final operation,
which is often the commit.
In general, increase in
read/write transaction time
is equal to increase
in lock contention
and consequently, increase
in abort rate in the system.
When we started out, we had
a lot of aborted transactions
because of lock contentions.
To have deeper understanding,
we built a transaction analyzer
to identify overlapping
transactions
and dig deeper into
each contention,
whether it is systemic
or whether it's
because of poor request
pattern, et cetera.
This allowed us to identify
the type of transactions
that can be read/write on abort
and the ones that should not.
This was important, as
the last thing you want
is all contending transactions
retrying forever, causing
mode churn and contentions.
For read-only
transactions, use snapshot
reads wherever possible to
increase your read performance.
This allows the reads to
be served from any replicas
and consequently, reduce
the load on the reader.
Let's look at an optimization
story with respect
to transaction execution.
In the first graph, you
can see we started off
with a basic read, modified
write example where we read,
then write, and finally commit.
In all, there were three
round trips to Spanner,
not including the
initial begin transaction
as we have a pool of
transactions ready to go.
Over time, our flows got
more complex where we often
had to do multiple reads and
writes within a transaction,
thus increasing the number
of round trips to Spanner.
Now, why does round
trip to Spanner matter?
Depending on where
your reader center is,
each Spanner round trip has
a regional network latency.
For example, if a transaction
has five round trips,
and if network latency
is 30 milliseconds,
you have lost 150 milliseconds
just to the network.
As we highlighted
earlier, keeping
the transaction
open for longer also
increases the chances
of contention.
So to solve for this,
we systematically
broke down the
transaction by identifying
the parts of transaction that
can happen in [INAUDIBLE]
by building a TransactionGraph.
This allowed us to issue
reads in [INAUDIBLE]
But writes were still
serialized as the BMLs needed
to be in sequence.
As illustrated in
graph three, this
allowed us to reduce the
round trips to Spanner
by just finalizing reads.
To solve for writes, we matched
all writes and commit together
in a single RTC using the
mutations API as provided
by Spanner.
To look at other
learnings with respect
to Spanner client-side
and service-side tunings,
I will hand it over to Ram.
RAMACHANDRAN IYER:
Thanks, Nanda.
So here are some of
the considerations
for client-side
performance and tuning.
We'll look at two main aspects
to tune on the client side--
sessions and gRPC.
We spoke about sessions
and session pool.
As part of session
pool configurations,
we recommend to
maintain or always
maintain necessary ratio
of read/write sessions
with the sessions that
are used only for reads.
A read/write
session is a session
associated with a
transaction using
the begin transaction API.
You can size your session pool
based on the expected workload
and transaction rate.
Also, session management APIs
that create sessions and batch
create sessions
have high latency.
It's better to
pre-provision sessions
instead of incurring costs
during transaction operations.
On the gRPC front,
we always need
to ensure to set appropriate
deadlines to the gRPC context.
We also learned
that comments should
be given more time to finish
compared to other operations.
For flow control,
gRPC streams are
bi-directional streams and
are mapped to HTTP/2 streams.
Payloads are serialized as
byte streams, which are then
fragmented into HTTP/2 frames.
gRPC uses flow control
mechanism in HTTP/2.
And this also helps in finer
grain control for buffering
in-flight messages.
We optimized our
flow control window
and depending on our
payload size, which
we found during our tests.
Compression-- this needs
to be carefully chosen
based on the payload size.
We found our product payloads
are highly compressible,
leading to bandwidth savings.
Currently, only Gs are supported
as part of the gRPC compression
codec.
We recommend on leveraging gRPC
interceptors for availability.
This can be plugged into
the client for introspection
and tracing.
From a server-side tuning point
of view, based on our testing,
we could scale
Spanner horizontally.
One of the core metrics
for scaling Spanner nodes
is CPU usage.
It's recommended to operate
below 75% on a smooth CPU
usage.
Spanner operational
management is simple,
and it's easy to provision more
nodes as and when you need it.
It's also important to
choose appropriate regions,
as Spanner offers a variety
of options like nam3, nam6,
and regional Spanner instances.
On the network side, since
we run our infrastructure
in our own data center,
it's important to have
an optimized routing
strategy to Spanner's server.
We work with GCP to
make this happen.
On the database
workload, Spanner
performs database splits and
compactions based on traffic.
This can be a load or
a size-based split,
which might have a
brief impact on latency.
It's important to have an
appropriate ramp-up strategy
so that there is minimal
disruptions during the split.
With all these learnings
and optimizations,
and along with the support
of the systems we built,
we performed
simulations on Spanner
with a synthetic
Uber scale load.
Before we look at
these numbers, it's
important to understand
these are strictly
dependent on data modeling
and how transactions are run.
This is highly use-case
specific and might not
apply to every use case.
Here are the
following highlights.
We were able to scale
Spanner nodes horizontally
in more than 600 nodes,
with a 330,000 per second--
reads per second and
130,000 writes per second.
CPU usage stayed close to 67%.
And in terms of
latency, we mainly
cared about the following RPCs--
ExecuteSQL, execute
BatchDML, and commit
latency, which were within
our acceptable latency
requirements.
We were also working on a
bunch of more optimizations
to better the performance.
So what are we doing next?
We're looking
towards building out
new features like forecasting
our Spanner nodes based
on predicted load and
optimize on CPU usage.
We are also looking forward to
testing a few Spanner features,
like Backup and Restore.
We'll also look at open sourcing
some of our work in the future.
Lastly, as we are working
on productionizing
our platform on a Cloud Spanner,
there's a whole team behind us.
And lots of people are
involved both on Uber
and from Google Cloud team.
As we embark on this journey,
we are looking forward
to this continued
collaboration and partnership.
On behalf of Nanda, I thank
you for watching the talk.